it is time for another Sunday
storytelling with Gregory Sadler that's
me and I have been running through some
of my favorite short stories of all time
many of which I've read as a younger
person and the one that I've got picked
out for today is no exception it is that
Hellbound train which you can find in
this book pleasant dreams Dash
Nightmares by Robert block who's written
many many great short stories and quite
a few excellent novels as well and so
this one I by the way I do recommend you
read the other stories in this this is
interesting too because the dedication
is for August duralith Fritz Leiber
Samuel peoples three who have shared my
nightmares and this is actually
published by Arkham house which is here
in Wisconsin if you don't now the
history of Arkham house it was founded
by durlith and I forget who the other
person was and they brought back into
publication among other people HP
Lovecraft stories so black is following
in a great progression
so I'm going to read this story that
Hellbound train and then afterwards we
can have some some chat you can leave
comments on the side and I'll respond to
them and I'll tell you before I jump
into it a little bit of how I came to
run into this story and why I find it so
fascinating and then maybe we'll have
some more discussion of that afterwards
so this is a perennial Trope of somebody
meeting the devil
and making a bargain with them and
you're going to notice that there's some
references in it to other deals that
people have made with the devil so
there's a little bit of what we call
intertextuality in black stuff even
though he sometimes has his characters
being a little bit dismissive of that
and this is one of the rare occasions
where the devil doesn't get his due as
you're going to find out now I read this
as a kid I don't know how how old I was
when I read it it was in one of those
Alfred Hitchcock anthologies that were
put together I think essentially for
young people but they had some pretty
adult stories in them and my uncle
Hubert who I've done a video actually
maybe two videos on was the person who
for every Christmas about five years in
a row would buy me
um
one of those Hitchcock anthologies so I
read this as a kid and I thought it was
a really cool story and on re-reading it
recently I actually think it's cooler
for reasons I'll tell you about so with
no further Ado let me launch into
reading this and then uh don't let me
forget because I've actually got another
idea about reading that I want to put
out there later on and get people's
taken so
that Hellbound Train by Robert block
when Martin was a little boy his daddy
was a railroad man he never rode the
high iron but he walked the tracks for
the CB and Q and he was proud of his job
and when he got drunk which was every
night he's saying this old song about
that hell-bound train Martin didn't
quite remember any of the words but he
couldn't forget the way his daddy sang
them out and when Daddy made the mistake
of getting drunk in the afternoon and
got squeezed between a Pennsy tank car
and an at an SNF Gondola Martin sort of
wondered why the Brotherhood didn't sing
the song at his funeral
after that things didn't go so good for
Martin but somehow he always recalled
daddy's song when Mom up and ran off
with a traveling salesman from Keokuk
daddy must have turned over in his grave
knowing she'd done such a thing and with
a passenger too
Martin hum the tune to himself every
night in the orphan home and after
Martin himself ran away he used to
Whistle the song at night in the jungles
after the other bindle stiffs were
asleep
Martin was on the road for four or five
years before he realized he wasn't
getting any place of
tried his hand at a lot of things fruit
in Oregon washing dishes of Montana hash
house but he just wasn't cut out for
seasonal labor or Pearl diving either
then he graduated to stealing hubcaps in
Denver for a while he did pretty good
with tires in Oklahoma City but by the
time he put in six months on the Chain
being down in Alabama he knew he had no
future drifting around this way on his
own
he tried to get on the railroad like his
daddy had
they told him times were bad and between
the truckers and the Airlines and those
fancy new fin Tails general motor was
making it looked as if the days of the
high Ballers were just about over
but Martin couldn't keep away from the
railroads wherever he traveled he rode
the rods he'd rather hop a freight
heading north in Sub-Zero weather then
lift his thumb to hitch a ride with a
Cadillac headed for Florida because
Martin was loyal to the memory of his
daddy and he wanted to be as much like
him as possible come what may of course
he couldn't get drunk every night but
whatever he did manage to get a hold of
a can of Sterno he'd sit there under a
nice warm Culvert and think about the
old days often is not he'd hum the song
about that hell-bound train that was the
Train the drunks and the Sinners Road
the gambling men and the grifters the
big time Spenders the skirt Chasers and
all the Jolly crew
it would be fun to take a trip in such
company but Martin didn't like to think
about what happened when that train
finally rolled into the depot down Way
Down Yonder
he didn't figure on spending eternity
stoking boilers in Hell Without Even a
company Union to protect him
still it would be a lovely ride if there
was such a thing as a Hellbound train
which of course there wasn't
at least Martin didn't think there was
until that evening when he found himself
walking the tracks heading south just
out of Appleton Junction the night was
cold and dark the way November nights
are in the Fox River Valley and he knew
he'd have to work his way down to New
Orleans for the Sun for the winter or
maybe even Texas
somehow he didn't feel much like going
even though he'd heard that a lot of
those Texas automobiles had solid gold
hubcaps no sir he just wasn't cut out
for petty larceny it was worse than a
sin it was unprofitable too bad enough
to do the devil's work but then to get
such miserable pay on top of it
maybe he'd better let the Salvation Army
convert him Martin trudged along humming
daddy's song Waiting for a rattler to
pull out of the junction behind him he'd
have to catch it there was nothing else
for him to do
too bad there wasn't a chance to make a
better deal for himself somewhere might
as well be a rich sinner as a poor
sinner besides he had a notion he could
strike a pretty shrewd bargain he'd
thought about it a lot these past few
years particularly when the Sterno was
working then his ideas would come on
strong and he could figure a way to rig
the setup but that was all nonsense of
course he might as well join the gospel
shouters and turn into a working stiff
like all the rest of the world no use
Dreaming Dreams a song was only a song
and there was no hell-bound train
there was only this train rumbling out
of the night roaring towards him along
the track from the south
Martin appeared ahead but his eyes
couldn't match his ears and so far all
he could recognize with the sound it was
a train though he felt the steel shutter
and sing beneath his feet and yet how
could it be the next Station South was
Nina Menasha and there was nothing due
out of there for hours
the clouds were thick overhead and the
field Miss roll like a cold fog at a
November midnight
even so Martin should have been able to
see the headlights as the train rushed
on but there were no lights
there was only the whistle
screaming out the black throw to the
night Martin could recognize the
equipment of just about any locomotive
ever built but he'd never heard a
whistle that sounded like this one it
wasn't signaling it was screaming like a
lost soul
he stepped to one side for the train was
almost on top of him now and suddenly
there it was looming along the tracks
and grinding to his stop unless time
he'd ever believed possible the wheels
hadn't been oiled because they screamed
too screamed like the Damned but the
train slid to a halt and the screams
died away into a series of low groaning
sounds and Martin looked up and saw that
it was a passenger train it was big and
black without a single light shining in
the engine cab or any of the long string
of cars and Martin couldn't read any of
the lettering on his sides but he was
pretty sure this train didn't belong on
the Northwestern Road he was even more
sure when he saw the man clamber down
out of the forward car
there was something wrong about the way
he walked as though one of his feet
dragged and there was something even
more disturbing about the lantern he
carried and what he did with it the
lantern was dark and when the man
alighted he held it up to his mouth and
blew
instantly the lantern glowed redly you
don't have to be a member of the Railway
Brotherhood to know that that is a
mighty peculiar way of lighting a
lantern
as the figure approached Martin
recognized the conductor's cat perched
on his head and this made him feel a
little better for a moment
until he noticed that it was worn a bit
too high as though there were might be
something sticking up on the forehead
underneath it
still Martin knew his manners and when
the man smiled at him he said good
evening Mr Conductor good evening Martin
how did you know my name the man
Shrugged how did you know I was the
conductor you are aren't you
to you yes although to other people in
other walks of life may recognize me in
different roles for instance you ought
to see what I look like to the folks out
in Hollywood the man grinned I travel a
great deal he explained
what brings you here Martin asked
why you ought to know the answer to that
Martin I came because you needed me I
did don't play the innocent ordinarily I
seldom bother with single individuals
anymore the way the world is going I can
expect to carry a full load of
passengers without soliciting business
your name has been down on the list for
several years already I reserved a seat
for you as a matter of course but then
tonight I suddenly realized you were
backsliding thinking of joining the
Salvation Army weren't you well Martin
hesitated don't be ashamed to err as
human as somebody or other once said
Reader's Digest was it never mind the
point is I felt you needed me so I
switched over and came your way
what for
why to offer you a ride of course isn't
it better to travel comfortably by train
than to March along the cold streets
behind a Salvation Army Band hard on the
feet they tell me and even harder on the
eardrums
I'm not sure I'd care to ride your train
sir Martin said considering where I'm
likely to end up ah yes the old argument
the conductor side I suppose you'd
prefer some sort of bargain is that it
exactly Martin answered
well I'm afraid I'm all through with
that sort of thing as I mentioned before
times have changed there's no shortage
of prospective passengers anymore why
should I offer you any special
inducements
you must want me or else you wouldn't
have bothered to go out of your way to
find me
the conductor side again
there you have a point Pride was always
my besetting weakness I'll admit and
somehow I'd hate to lose you to the
competition thinking of you as my own
all these years he hesitated
yes I'm prepared to deal with you on
your own terms if you insist the terms
Martin asked standard proposition
anything you want ah said Martin but I
warn you in advance there will be no
tricks I'll Grant you any wish you can
name but in return you must promise to
ride the train when the time comes
suppose it never comes oh it will
suppose I've got the kind of wish that
will keep me off forever
there is no such wish
don't be so sure
let me worry about that the conductor
told him no matter what you have in mind
I'll warn you that I'll collect in the
end and there'll be none of this last
minute Hocus Pocus either no last minute
repentance no bra blonde fra lines or
fancy lawyers showing up to get you off
I offer a clean deal that is to say
you'll get what you want and I'll get
what I want
I've heard you trick people they say
you're worse than a used car salesman
now wait a minute I apologize Martin
said hastily but it is supposed to be a
fact that you can't be trusted
I admit it on the other hand you send
you seem to think you found a way out a
Surefire proposition
Surefire very funny the man began to
chuckle then halted but we waste
valuable time Martin let's get down to
cases what do you want from me
a single wish
name it and I shall Grant it anything
you said anything at all
very well that Martin took a deep breath
I want to be able to stop time
right now no no not yet and not for
everybody I realize the world would this
that would be impossible of course but I
want to be able to stop time for myself
just once in the future whenever I get
to a point when I know I'm happy and
contented that's where I'd like to stop
so I can just keep on being happy
forever
that's quite a proposition the conductor
Muse I've got to admit I've never heard
anything just like it before and believe
me I've listened to some lulus in my day
he grinned at Martin you really been
thinking about this haven't you
for years Martin admitted then he
coughed well what do you say
it's not impossible in terms of your own
subjective time sense the conductor
murmured yes I think it could be
arranged
but I mean really to stop not just for
me to imagine it
I understand and it can be done
then you'll agree why not I promised you
didn't I give me your hand
Martin hesitated will it hurt very much
I mean I don't like the sight of blood
and nonsense you've been listening to a
lot of poppycock we already made our
bargain my boy no need for a lot of
childish rigmarole I'm merely intend to
put something in your hand the ways and
means of fulfilling your wish after all
there's no telling at just what moment
you may decide to exercise the agreement
and I can't drop everything and come
running so it's better if you can
regulate matters for yourself
you're going to give me a time stopper
that's the general idea as soon as I can
decide what would be practical the
conductor hesitated ah the very thing
here take my watch
he pulled it out of his vest pocket a
railroad watch in a silver case he
opened the back and made a delicate
adjustment Martin tried to see just
exactly what he was doing but the
fingers moved in a blinding blur there
we are the conductor smiled it's all set
now when you finally decide where you'd
like to call a halt merely turn the stem
in reverse and unwind the watch until it
stops when it stops time stops for you
simple enough
sure thing then here take it and the
conductor dropped the watch into
Martin's hand
the young man closed his fingers tightly
around the case that's all there is to
it eh absolutely but remember you can
stop the watch only once so you better
make sure you're satisfied with the
moment you choose to prolong I caution
you in all fairness make very certain of
your choice
I will Martin Grant and since you've
been so fair about it I'll be fair too
there's one thing you seem to have
forgotten it doesn't really
real moment I choose because once I stop
time for myself that means I stay where
I am forever I never have to get any
older and if I don't get any older I'll
never die and if I never die then I'll
never have to take a ride on your train
the conductor turned away his shoulders
Shook convulsively and he may have been
crying
and you said I was worse than a used car
salesman he gasped in a strangled voice
then he wandered off in the fog and the
train whistle gave an impatient shriek
and all at once it was moving swiftly
down the track rumbling out of sight in
the darkness Martin stood there blinking
down at the silver watch in his hand if
it wasn't that he could actually see it
and feel it there and if he couldn't
smell that particular order he might
have thought that he'd imagine the whole
thing from start to finish train
conductor bargain and all
but he had the watch and he could
recognize the scent left by the train as
it departed even though there aren't
many locomotives around that use sulfur
and brimstone as fuel
and he had no doubts about his bargain
better still he had no doubts as to the
advantages of The Pact he had made
that's what came of thinking things
through to a logical conclusion some
fools might have settled for wealth or
power or Kim Novak Daddy might have sold
out for a fifth of whiskey Martin knew
he'd made a better deal
better it was foolproof all I needed to
do now was to choose his moment and when
the right time came it was his forever
he put his watch in his pocket and
started down the railroad track he
hadn't really a destination in mind
before but he did now he was gonna find
a moment of happiness
now young Martin wasn't altogether a
ninny he realized perfectly well that
happiness is a relative thing there are
conditions and degrees of contentment
and they vary with one's lot in life as
a hobo he was often satisfied with a
warm handout a double length bench in
the park or a can of Sterno made in 1957
a vintage Year many a time he'd reached
a state of momentary Bliss through such
agencies but he was aware that there
were better things Martin determined to
seek them out
within two days he was in the great city
of Chicago
quite naturally he drifted over to West
Madison Street and he took steps to
elevate his role in life he became a
city bomb a panhandler a moocher within
a week he'd risen to the point where
happiness was a meal and a regular
one-arm luncheon joint a two-bit flop on
a real army caught in a real Flop House
and a full fifth of Muscatel
there was a night after enjoying all
three of these luxuries to the full when
Martin was tempted to unwind his watch
at the Pinnacle of intoxication
then he remembered the faces of the
honest Johns he'd braced for a handout
today
true they were squares but they were
prosperous
they wore good clothes held good jobs
drove nice cars
and for them happiness was even more
ecstatic the dinner and fine hotels
slept on inner spring mattresses they
drank blended whiskey squares or no they
had something there
Martin fingered his watch put aside the
temptation to hock it for another bottle
of Muscatel and went to sleep
determining to get himself a job and
improve his happiness quotient when he
awoke he had a hangover but the
determination was still with him it
stayed long after The Hangover
disappeared and before the month was out
Martin found himself working for a
general contractor over on the South
Side one of the big Rehabilitation
projects he hated the grind but the pay
was good and pretty soon he got himself
a one-room apartment out on Blue Island
Avenue
he was accustomed to eating in decent
restaurants now and he bought himself a
comfortable bed and every Saturday night
he went down to The Corner Tavern it was
all very pleasant but
the foreman liked his work and promised
him a raise in a month if he waited
around the raise would mean he could
afford a second-hand car with a car he
could even start picking up a girl for a
date now and then lots of other fellows
on the job did and they seemed pretty
happy so Martin kept on working and the
raise came through and the car came
through and pretty soon a couple of
girls came through
the first time it happened he wanted to
unwind his watch immediately until he
got to thinking about what some of the
older men always said there was a guy
named Charlie for example who worked
alongside him on the Hoist
are young and don't know the score maybe
you get a kick of running around with
those pigs but after a while you want
something better
a nice girl of your own that's the
ticket
well he might have something there at
least Martin owed it to himself to find
out if he didn't like it better he could
always go back to what he had it was
worth a try
of course nice girls don't grow on trees
if they did a lot more men would become
forest rangers and almost six months
went by before Martin met Lillian Gillis
by the end time he'd had another
promotion and was working inside in the
office they made him to go to night
school to learn how to do simple
bookkeeping but it meant another 15
bucks extra a week and it was nicer
working indoors
and Lillian was a lot of fun when she
told him she'd marry him Martin was
almost sure the time was now except that
she was sort of well she was a nice girl
and she said they'd have to wait until
they were married of course Martin
couldn't expect to marry her until he
had a little more money saved up and
another raise would help too that took a
year
Martin was patient because he knew it
was going to be worth it every time he
had any doubts he took out his watch and
he looked at it but he never showed it
to Lillian or anybody else most of the
other men were expensive wrist watches
and the old silver railroad watch looked
just a little cheap
Martin smiled as he gazed at the stem
just a few twists and he'd have
something none of those other poor
working slobs would ever have permanent
satisfaction with his Blushing Bride
only getting married turned out to be
just the beginning sure it was wonderful
but Lillian told him how much better
things would be if they could move into
a new place and fix it up Martin wanted
decent Furniture a TV set a nice car so
he started taking night courses and got
a promotion of the front office
with the baby coming he wanted to stick
around and see his son arrive and when
it came he realized he'd have to wait
until it got a little older started to
walk and talk and develop a personality
of its own
about this time the company sent him out
on the road as a troubleshooter on some
of those other jobs and now he was
eating at those good hotels living high
on the hog and the expense account more
than once he was tempted to unwind his
watch this was the good life
and he realized it could be even better
if he just didn't have to work sooner or
later
if he could cut in on one of the company
deals he could make a pile and retire
then everything would be ideal
it happened but it took time Martin's
son was going to high school before he
really got up there in the chips Martin
got the feeling it was now or never
because he wasn't exactly a kid anymore
but right about then he met Sherry
Westcott and she didn't seem to think he
was middle aged at all in spite of the
way he was losing hair and adding
stomach she taught him a toupee could
cover the bald spot and a cumberbund
could cover the pot gut in fact she
taught him quite a number of things and
he so enjoyed learning that he actually
took out his watch and prepared to
unwind it unfortunately he chose the
very moment when the private detectives
broke down the door to the hotel room
and there was a long stretch of time
when Martin was so busy fighting the
divorce action he couldn't say honestly
he was enjoying any given amount when he
made his final settlement with Lily was
broke again
and Sherry didn't seem to think he was
so young after all so he squared his
shoulders and went back to work
he made his pile eventually but it took
longer this time and there wasn't much
chance to have fun along the way the
fancy names and the fancy Cocktail
Lounges didn't seem to interest him
anymore neither did the liquor besides
the doc had warned him about that but
there were other Pleasures for a rich
man to investigate travel for instance
and not riding the rods from one
hickberg to another either Martin went
around the world via plain and luxury
liner
for a while it seemed as if he would
find his moment after all visiting the
Taj Mahal By Moonlight the moon's
Radiance was reflected from the back of
the battered old watch case
and Martin got ready to unwind it nobody
else was there to watch him and that's
why he hesitated
sure this was an enjoyable moment but he
was alone Lil and the kid were gone
Sherry was gone and somehow he'd never
had time to make any friends
maybe if he found a few congenial people
he'd have the ultimate happiness
that must be the answer it wasn't just
money or power or sex or seeing
beautiful things the real satisfaction
lay in friendship
so on the boat home Martin tried to
strike up a few acquaintances at the
ship's bar but all these people were so
much younger and Martin had nothing in
common with them also they wanted to
dance and drink and Martin wasn't in
condition to appreciate such pastimes
nevertheless he tried
perhaps that's why he had the little
accident the day before they docked in
San Francisco little accident was the
way the ship's doctor had of describing
it but Martin looked he looked noticed
he looked very grave when he told him to
stay in bed and he called an ambulance
to meet the liner at the dock and take
the patient right to the hospital
at the hospital they all the expensive
treatment and expansive smiles and the
expensive words didn't fool Martin any
he was an old man with a bad heart and
they thought he was going to die but he
could fool them
he still had the watch
he found it in his coat when he put on
his clothes and sneaked out of the
hospital before Dawn he didn't have to
die he could cheat death with a single
gesture and he intended to do it as a
free man under a free sky that was the
real Secret Of Happiness he understood
it now not even friendship meant as much
as freedom
this is the best thing of all to be free
of friends or family or the furies of
the flesh
Martin walked slowly beside the
embankment under the night sky come to
think of it he was just about back where
he started so many years ago but the
moment was good good enough to prolong
forever once a bum always a bum he
smiled as he thought about it and then
the smile Twisted sharply and suddenly
like the pain twisting sharply and
suddenly in his chest the world began to
spin and he fell down the side of the
embankment
he couldn't see very well but he was
still conscious and he knew what had
happened another stroke and a bad one
maybe this was it except he wouldn't be
a fool any longer he wouldn't wait to
see what was still around the corner
right now was his chance to use his
power and save his life and he was going
to do it he could still move nothing
could stop him
he groped in his pocket pulled out the
old silver watch fumbling with the stem
a few twists and he'd shoot death
he'd never have to ride that Hellbound
train he could go on forever
forever
Martin had never really considered that
word before to go on forever but how
did he want to go on forever like this a
sick old man lying helplessly there in
the grass
no he couldn't do it he wouldn't do it
and suddenly he wanted very much to cry
because he knew that somewhere along the
line he'd outsmarted himself and now it
was too late his eyes dimmed there was
this roaring in his ears he recognized
the Roaring of course and he wasn't at
all surprised to see the train come
rushing out of the fog there on the
embankment he wasn't surprised when it
stopped there either or when the
conductor climbed off and walked slowly
towards him the conductor hadn't changed
a bit even his grin was still the same
hello Martin he said all aboard I know
Martin whispered but you'll have to
carry me I can't walk I'm not even
really talking anymore am I yes you are
the conductor said I can hear you just
fine and you can walk too he leaned down
and placed his hand on Martin's chest
there was a moment of icy numbness and
then sure enough Martin could walk after
all
he got up and followed the conductor
along the slope moving to the side of
the train
in here he asked
no the next car the conductor murmured I
guess you're entitled to ride Pullman
after all you're quite a successful man
you've tasted the joys of wealth and
position and Prestige you've known the
pleasures of marriage and fatherhood you
sample the Delights of dining and
drinking and debauchery too and you
traveled High wide and handsome so let's
not have any last minute recriminations
all right Martin side I guess I can't
blame you for my mistakes on the other
hand you can't take credit for what
happened either I worked for everything
I got I did it all on my own I didn't
even need your watch
so you didn't the conductor said smiling
but would you mind giving it back to me
now
need it for the next sucker eh Martin
muttered perhaps
something about the way he said it made
Martin look up
he tried to see the conductor's eyes but
the brim of his hat cast a shadow so
Martin looked down at the watch instead
as if seeking an answer there
tell me something he said softly if I
give you the watch what will you do with
it
why throw it into the dish the conductor
told him that's all I'll do with it and
he held out his hand
what if somebody comes along and finds
it and twists the stem backwards and
stops time
nobody would do that the conductor
murmured even if they knew
you mean it was all a trick this is only
an ordinary cheap watch oh I didn't say
that whispered the conductor I only said
that no one has ever Twisted the stem
backwards they've all been like you
Martin looking ahead to find that
perfect happiness waiting for the moment
that never comes again the conductor
held out his hand again
Martin aside and shook his head you
cheated me after all
you cheated yourself Martin and now
you're gonna ride that hell-bound train
he pushed Martin up the steps and into
the car ahead as he entered the train
began to move and the whistle screamed
and Martin stood there in the swaying
Pullman gazing down the aisle at the
other passengers he could see them
sitting there and somehow it didn't seem
strange at all
here they were the drunks and the
Sinners the Gambling Man and the
grifters the big time Spenders the skirt
Chasers and all the Jolly crew they all
knew where they were going of course but
they didn't seem to be particularly
concerned at the moment the blinds were
drawn on the Windows yet it was light
outside and they were all sitting around
and singing and passing the bottle and
laughing it up telling their jokes
bragging their brags just like the way
daddy used to sing about them in the old
song
mighty fine traveling companions Martin
said well I've never seen such a
pleasant bunch of people I mean they
seem to be really enjoying themselves
sorry the conductor told them I'm afraid
things may not be quite so enjoyable
once we pull into that Depot Way Down
Yonder for the third time he held out
his hand now before you sit down
if you'll just give me that watch I mean
a bargain's a bargain
Martin smiled bargain's a bargain he
echoed I agreed to ride your time if I
could stop your train if I could stop
time when I found the right moment of
happiness
so if you don't mind I think I'll just
make certain adjustments very slowly
Martin twistered Twisted the silver
watch stem no said the conductor no but
the watch stem turned do you realize
what you've done the conductor panted
now we'll never reach the depot we'll
just go riding all of us forever and
ever
Martin grid I know but the Fun's in the
trip not the destination you taught me
that and I'm looking forward to a
wonderful trip
the conductor groaned
all right he sighed at last you've got
the best of me after all but when I
think of spending eternity trapped here
riding this train
cheer up Martin said it won't be that
bad looks like we have plenty to eat and
drink after all these are your kind of
folks
but I'm the conductor think of the
Endless work this means for me don't let
it worry you Martin said look maybe I
can even help if you were to find me
another one of those caps now and let me
keep this watch
and that's the way it finally worked out
wearing his cap and carrying his
battered old silver watch there's no
happier person in the world in or out of
the world now and forever than Martin
Martin the new break man on that
Hellbound train
and that is the end of the story that
Hellbound trained by Robert block which
you can find in this wonderful Anthology
pleasant dreams Dash nightmares
um among one of my among my favorite
short stories I won't say it's my
absolute favorite because I don't have
one but it's certainly up there and I'm
glad I could share this story which
notice there's a lot of cool stuff uh
built in there I may actually use this
for classes down the line there's
Reflections on what is human happiness
what goes into it how do we attain
happiness and then the whole theme of
the deal with the devil and it looks
until the very end as if the devil has
actually won but Martin finds a way to
subvert the very bargain that they're
involved in about the Hellbound train so
that is uh you know quite interesting
and block of course is a great author
um
it's always a lot of fun reading his his
stuff so uh JB says I remember trick the
devil stories we're not too uncommon in
the horror comics of my youth in the 70s
yeah I think I recall that also being a
theme that we'd see sometimes on TV
shows you know
it's a a great premise you've got
a power that is not good but can grant
you what you think is good
and we'll do so at the price of your
soul
and you know the the goal is to exchange
something for greater value and there's
usually a Twist right the devil doesn't
um give you something
that's going to work out for you in the
end right and we see this uh coming up
over and over again as a a Trope as a
motif uh throughout time
all right uh Perpetual vinyl says hope
is happiness
um yeah for some people I mean one of
the things that we we notice about this
story is there is not a happiness that
is for everybody so we have to avoid
General statements about what happiness
consists in and Martin doesn't need hope
um he's on that Hellbound train at the
end it's actually the hope of Greater
happiness it had that screwed him in
this right and now that he's actually on
the train he's like well this is this is
as good as it's going to get and this is
pretty good
so he
pulls the the stem and twists it JB says
overly sarcastic Productions just
recently did a nice video on Faustian
Bargains that might be fun yeah maybe
I'll I'll check it out well we'll see I
don't know overly sarcastic Productions
but maybe it could be quite interesting
um
so I'll I'll take questions comments uh
address whatever people want to bring up
um in in the meantime and we got about
another 20 minutes or so before I go off
to visit the cats at the cat Refuge and
get my little dose of feline interaction
so which is part of happiness for me you
know a certain kind of companionship
certain kind of animal and hopefully I
give them a little bit of happiness as
well so
um Perpetual vinyl memories Robert block
novels a whole bunch of them you can
easily Google it and uh find them
um
if I remember right he is best known
for uh psycho right
um
yep psycho he's written a lot of other
weird Tales Cosmic horror and stuff like
that oh interestingly enough this uh
story that Hellbound train won the Hugo
award and the brown stoker award and the
world fantasy award I just always
thought of it as a great story what do I
recommend I recommend reading as much as
you want
um I don't I don't make a lot of
recommendations there's so much stuff
out there that you can read and reread
all right so JB says in OSP they talk
about how power granting the wish is
usually malign yeah and the theme of the
tragic Doom of the protagonist generally
reinforces a Christian frame earlier
stuff has more underdogs that manage to
win out by cleverness
yeah and you notice in this story The
Devil adapts to Changing Times which is
quite interesting isn't it you know
so um
yeah I I suppose so if we think about
this like in terms of
um other powerful entities that you can
be engaged in like I'm thinking about
Descartes Mata and Janie or you know
Evil Genius or evil demon that could be
deceiving him about everything and of
course if you read the rest of the
meditations You Realize by the end of
meditation three that there isn't any
such thing right that God is is not a
deceiver but
um the Devil is a a deceiver in in these
uh stories and in Descartes case
it's just trying to trick him it's not
trying to make them happy it's trying to
make him not question the existence that
he's in right in this case it's really
about one's heart desires one's
happiness what it is that you value most
greatly uh usia says horror Babel does
great readings of horror stories and of
the few by block I'll take your word for
that I spend very little time watching
other people's videos or listening to
other people's podcasts because time is
short and uh there's so much content out
there that I you know spend more time
like you know rereading stuff like this
um
Perpetual vinyl memories Kurt Vonnegut
says somebody gets in trouble then gets
out of it again people love that story
they never get tired of it yeah although
that's super generic and uh I think it
what we want to attend to less is like
these super super high level generic
stuff and the more the the specificity
specificity of what's being put out
there and I think that's part of what
makes this a great story we have the you
know age-old question what is human
happiness how do we get it we have the
deal with the devil Motif and then we
have the changing conditions of
um the interactions of the supernatural
which is quite interesting Rob Street
would you recommend Byron's cane a
mystery for a meeting to change
perceptions I don't even know it so I
wouldn't recommend it uh I'm not as
you're going to find out super
particularly well read as a person so
I'm usually
um not not giving an awful lot of
recommendation about stuff any other
questions comments that people have uh
that they want to bring up
particularly about this story and it's
it's great themes
all right uh Perpetual vinyl memories
what does the train symbolize hell I
presume no it doesn't symbolize hell at
all because that's the depot Down Yonder
that the train is going to the train is
just a way to get down to Hell and it's
a it's a nice train to ride up
apparently if you're a sinner which
apparently everybody on there is right
you got some some nice stuff it doesn't
symbolize life because it's after your
life it doesn't symbolize suffering
because you're not suffering on the
train I would not try to make the train
symbolize anything I would instead take
the train as what it is in the narrative
uh JB says the comic I remember was a
scientist who sold her soul in order to
be able to cure a terrible plague she
used her super science to clone herself
so perfectly the devil could not choose
between them rather subversive around
the question of what the soul is now
that is a funny one because that assumes
that the devil is going to to play fair
right so that if the devil can't figure
out which is the real person that he
made the deal with that
um he will
um
you know
not take anybody in and I could well
imagine a devil saying you know because
they're they're a devil they're a bad
person saying well I'll just take both
of you instead right and maybe also that
guy over there because he is evil and
um who would be holding the devil to
following the rules of something like
British American jurisprudence where
you're innocent until you know proven
guilty which is not the case in most
legal systems so yeah that's that's an
interesting one right there
um all right any other questions
comments uh this is a wonderful little
story
um I'll be doing actually next next
month I'm gonna be doing
um the king of cats and I forget exactly
the name of the author offhand another
one of the stories that I read in one of
those Alfred Hitchcock anthologies as a
kid and I really love the story I also
am thinking about doing something a
little bit more extensive sometime this
summer I've been rereading Graham greens
the ministry of fear which is a
wonderful book as is there so many of
Graham Green's
novels this one is actually one that he
calls an entertainment
and I've been thinking about doing a
reading where I would
um
spread it out over days and read there's
about you know close to 14 portions of
the book so I could do you know
um two each day over the course of a
week at a particular set time and just
read my way through it and I think that
could be fun so I'll probably put some
polls out there on
um
you know my social media and maybe
YouTube and see what people happen to
think about that and I think that could
be quite enjoyable so
um we'll see about that but we're
certainly going to be doing more and
more of these short story readings
um
JB says you could do a book just on the
weird legalisms around the fairy world
and their Bargains yeah I mean I would
rise if somebody already hasn't done a
study of that
um I think if we were to like do some
searching we probably could dig
something up Perpetual vinyl memories do
you like Lawrence Darrell I've never
even heard of Lawrence Durrell so I'm I
can't like them
um JB says very good reading by the way
you could totally do audiobooks as
another side gig yeah it's kind of fun
to do I've never actually done this
before before I started doing these
um I'll tell you who is actually doing
that stuff and who's got some of their
stuff on LibriVox my oldest child cat
Sadler has been contributing
um tracks on LibriVox if you don't know
LibriVox it's a massive repository
that's been around for decades of
volunteers reading
audiobooks uh chapter by chapter section
by section and uh there's some really
cool stuff there on that site I spent
many a time doing long distance drives
downloading them and putting them onto
CDs and listening to them along the way
all right well
doesn't look like there's any more
questions or comments so I am going to
wrap up here and I'm going to go and see
some cats and then I gotta get back to
work unfortunately
um
Rob says thanks for the reading Cane's a
must thanks for the Lucian cynic episode
catch you next time sounds good so I
will see all of you hope you have a
great rest of the day or if you're
overseas evening or whatever it happens
to be for you and you'll see the rest of
you know these these uh getting put on
my channel well in advance and hopefully
you can join me for some of the other
ones I'll see you later